moi je suis pour une opposition
parle pour ma famille politique et et
nos amis de l'udps et y pour une
opposition qui soient indépendantes
clairs et qu'ils soient utiles au pays
donc il n'est pas question ni de fusion
ni de coalition pourquoi pas parce que
là pour quelles raisons vous ne pourriez
le réseau s'est exclu nous ne pouvons
pas laisser l'opposition
à
la seule france insoumise et à ses
alliés qui se sont rangés sans
commentaire derrière la france a soumis
et au rassemblement national je pense
que nous avons une responsabilité
démocratique mais à chaque fois que ce
sera utile au pays comme nous le faisons
au sénat
comme nous le faisons au sénat notamment
depuis trois ans la maison quand c'est
pour nous un sujet sur lui quand votre
enfant votre position de l'armée mais
c'est un gouverneur donc soit on ne peut
pas gouverner c'est le président de la
république c'est lui qui a conduit la
majorité
séduit qui continuent à la conduire
jusqu'au deuxième tour je pense que nous
avons une responsabilité nous les
républicains et nos alliés de l'udps et
d'avoir plus grand nombre de députés
pour cette ligne et je répète
indépendante claires et utiles au pays
nous voulons collectivement être utile
au pays que ce soit l'assemblée
nationale ou le sénat notamment travers
de la majorité sénatoriale